bb8 was birth like many great works of
engineering before him as a crude sketch
on the back of the napkin director JJ
Abrams drew two circles one on top of
another with a tiny dot for an eye
basic but the core concept was there in
total the team made seven bb-8 droids
for various uses it took twelve people
four months to complete the work the BVA
versions include a stunt bb-8 and a
bowling ball version in case they needed
a madcap BBA to worse through the frame
puppeteer bb-8 a functional robot
operated by up to three robot assists
there was also a lightweight bb-8 which
could be carried by the actors if
necessary
he weighs approximately 40 pounds and
stands at two feet two and a half inches
tall that makes him shorter than r2d2
his head swivels a full 360 degrees and
he has six swappable circular tool bay
discs when he does get going
watch out because his top speed is just
under 7 miles per hour you may think
bb-8 is powered by pure cuteness but
it's ni MH batteries might be a part of
the equation it takes 2 hours to fully
charge him
speaking of high-powered machines the
Japanese airline ene has decked out
three commercial jets in Star Wars
livery including one plane themed after
bb-8 bb-8 uses a gyroscope to determine
which way is down and two wheels to move
the sphere from inside the base plate
serves as a counterweight to keep the
wheels acting against the lower half of
the sphere yeah that might be an over
explanation some machines are just a
couple spheres on top of each other with
some wires inside thanks JJ